well you're also looking very good i
don't know if you are aware of how good
the internet thinks you look it's like
all everyone's talking about lately i
think you might be no i'm not
i'm really not ben um i is it the jlo
glow like how much happiness is she
bringing into your life because you're
looking good man is it the corduroy is
that what you're big on the quarter
because i wasn't sure about where they
told me it's fall that right there is
ben affleck playing coy about his
rekindled romance with jennifer lopez
i'm thrilled in fact things seem to be
going so well for benefer that a source
tells et they're madly in love and will
eventually get engaged the source tells
et their families get along well saying
things between their children are pretty
organic at this point the families
respect each other and also get along so
things are all good and fine on that
front their friends think they will get
engaged eventually and it's only a
matter of time in november jennifer said
she's down to tie the knot again
i always have been i've been married a
few times
um
yeah i still believe in happily ever
after for sure j lo served us wedding
white when the couple made their first
red carpet appearance together in 18
years at the venice film festival three
months later she joined ben at the
premiere of the tender bar but opted for
something blue straight up like in my
gym shorts what if i rolled up here you
know what i mean it would be okay
because the way your woman looked today
i mean my god you came with the damn
goddess
there you go well then i should probably
wear my shorts next time and when it
comes to the pair's famous pals like
matt damon they're all in that's great
it's it's wonderful and i'm just happy
to see uh see my friend really happy now
benefer is no stranger to public
scrutiny and fans had a lot to say after
ben's interview with howard stern last
month even the relationship now i i see
you're with jennifer that even brings
more attention to you you've been
through that scene where you're
constantly in the tablet was there
hesitation on your part to say just you
know i can't go through this again you
know uh it crossed my mind for sure that
well look my response to my children is
the highest responsibility i have so
nothing i can't do anything that's
that's painful or destructive to them if
i can help it that being said you know
i know that my life affects them so how
did the blowback from the interview
affect the couple our source says jen
and ben are doing great ben's interview
with howard stern didn't really put too
much of a strain on their relationship
they understand that things like this
happen sometimes and words can get
misconstrued adding quote they are madly
in love and jen totally has ben's back
the 52 year old singer and the 49 year
old actor have a lot of history together
they first started dating in 2002 and
got engaged that year but by 2004 they'd
call off the wedding it was my first
kind of heartbreak it was just one of
those things you know i was an adult we
were about to get married it didn't work
out and it was just
a bad heartbreak like you know just one
of those breakups that really
you know it was like
a tough one for me for whatever reason
for many reasons
fast forward to 2022 and the couple is
back together and going strong if jlo's
jewelry is any indication
[Music]
on tuesday the marry me actress shared
this pic on instagram it's like elegant
and beautiful yep that's a necklace with
ben's name on it here's hoping we'll see
more jewels like a ring in the near
future
[Music]